honestly if your name is Chameli
sha'lame that's too much I changed my
last name he should consider it he'd
have a much bigger like the size of mine
you know what I mean
everybody welcome to the other show I'm
Sarah and I'm Chris and we are here
talking about episode four with Halina
drew and case Walker yes not as cool and
sucks to hear this was my last whoo
thank God that was the final one high
school dance next week maybe chase could
be my date I was doing music he's on a
broken iPod in my lip sync videos on a
broken iPod in my room and it just kind
of started going up and my mom was like
we went to the mall one day and someone
was like hey can I get a picture with
your son and my mom's like what's going
on here does she has no clue what's
going on either so then she got into it
and that's kind of how it started just
in my room just doing what I like and
and having fun with it yeah the gays are
turning on the vid they're saying it's
quote so five years ago there is an
entire world of people that you know
that I don't know our alone yeah yeah
and people that we all know and think
are incredibly famous I'm sorry yeah so
I was like I want to throw out some
names and see if you know if they're a
person have you ever heard of Helen
Mirren no you've never heard the name
Helen Mirren I've never heard the name
Helen Mirren it's like usually I'll tell
you if I've actually heard them but if I
know what do you think la Miran does
actually sounds like an actor I want to
do like why do you want to say that
comedy Jennifer Lawrence oh yes okay do
you know who's Steve Carell is yes I've
heard his name I don't know who he is I
couldn't if you showed me his face I
wouldn't know but I know his name
Wow do you know who Timothy shamili is
no you know who Timothy sha'lame is yeah
I do know people see if we know of
anybody OC okay Jas I never heard
radiation david dobrik no no no it's not
as fun this way why is it co she Isaac
oh she she's good alien tomorrow Isaac
so she is your helen mirren
what is it you tuber do yeah I think
it's cool so I remember like right when
we were starting shooting they were like
yeah so we just need like 200 photos of
you and your childhood and I was like oh
God and like videos too and I was like
oh no I mean I have to like watch a
bunch of videos they like make you sad
so I got a bunch of them and they were
like hey do you mind if we reach out to
some of your Facebook friends from high
school and I was just kind of like oh
yeah those people I haven't talked to in
like 10 years yeah yeah yeah let's um
let's reach out to them but it was like
hey I sort of need photos from anyone
you've ever met at any point in your
life yeah I actually reconnected with
some people and I was like hey I'm on a
show now and I'm do you have any photos
of me being weird at parties keeps
happening why do you keep showing up his
one time out of ten it really is a dying
girl and if you don't show up it's bad
optics and pink doesn't do bad optics
she does near-constant
aerial domestics yeah I don't want to
insult any of my fans here but um so I
had a fan I don't know it was this one
girl when she was being really extreme
and the DM she was like case I'm dying
you need to and she was saying all this
really serious stuff and so then we went
we went into it because she was doing it
for months she was like saying she's
gonna die and that if I didn't do
anything she would die like not do so it
was it was very serious and sad and so I
was concerned so eventually I was like
I'm not gonna send her flowers to like
someone who I don't even know is real or
actually dying so and we ended up
calling the hospital and seeing if the
girl was actually dying and then a
couple weeks later we found the photo
online that she had posted so it was
actually a put she stirred up like a
disease and then took a photo of like a
young girl and put it on our Pole
so disgusting it's bad yeah that's crazy
yeah it was pretty you're a great
storyline is your chase trees I've been
in the hospital for seven weeks and it's
not looking good could you send me a
t-shirt you're my favorite singer ever
loved Rachel Kline poor girl such
terrible taste in music I wrote to
Nutella oh boy um I wrote them I was
like Hello
I love Nutella this is the greatest
product ever um thank you so much for
all that you do and they sent me coupons
for free Nutella whoa
and then when they sent me free coupons
I was like hmm and so I wrote like Ben
and Jerry's and I was like where are my
coupons I remember I waited in line at
the mall for four hours to meet Candace
Cameron to be who Candace Cameron you
know I don't know that I'm like trying
to remember she's a full house she's the
mom on fuller oh I can't think it out
this is the rough
[Music]
you